Bob: You ready to probably die a bunch?
Mark: yeah.
Mark: okay. Yeah, okay. All right.
Mark: Okay. I'm just going through the control tutorial
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I'm just. Hang on. *while giggling at himself*
Bob: It's - It's just right click to spinny spinny left click to-
Mark: Du-[de]
Bob: (cont.)- do-ey do-ey. We got it, we got it. Mark: alright, okay
Mark: okay so i'm in,
Mark: uhhhhhh
Mark: The first bomb do I just go have the first bomb? Bob: Yeah. We just start at the beginning. Mark: Okay
Mark: *reading* Everybody has to start somewhere
Let's just hope it doesn't end here too. Make sure your experts have the manual and are ready to help
Bob: That's me. Mark: All right, here we go. *reading* This screen is for your eyes only
You are not allowed to look at the bomb defusal manual
Okay. Bob: That would be pretty hard for us to accomplish in this current distance arrangement. Mark: Alright, let's do this
So does this start as soon as I pick- Oh it's started! Okay. Bob: Yeah, it starts. It starts. Okay. So what-what are you seein'?
Mark: I know the general gist of it. We've got wires. We've got funky signal- s-symbols, and we've got a big blue button.
Bob: Okay, let's see wires first. Mark: Wires. Okay, what's up? Bob: How many are there?
Mark: Alright, there's six wires, Bob: Oh Lord okay, are there any yellow wires?
Mark: There are three yellow wires. in the two, three, and five positions Bob: are there red wires?
Mark: one red wire. fourth position.
Bob: Cut the fourth wire. and I believe you start at the top and count down Mark: Cool. All right, green. We're good.
We've got Greek symbols, or weird funky symbols. Bob: sym-symbols. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, okay uhhhh
Bob: What is the top left symbol?
Mark: "O" WITH A PENIS Bob: uhhhh, what is the bottom left symbol?
It is a lambda with a cross through the top.B: Top right symbol? M: It's an H. That's on acid
It's real curvy. B: And, no I totally got you. Yeah, and then what's the last one? M: It's a
Backwards C with a butthole. B: Okay, so you're gonna push the buttons in this order. M: Uh-huh. B: O with the penis. M: penis. B: lambda
M: Lambda. B: psychedelic H. M: H. B: backwards C. M: Got it, green. All right, we got big blue button. B: Alright big button
What does the button say? M: it says press. B: how many batteries are there around the Bomb?
There will be some modules that have like double a's in them. M: There's two double a's one d battery
That's it. B: Is there a lit indicator next to a label that says "frk" on it?
M: uhhhhhhhhhhhh....
M: No. B: Okay now press and hold the button keep holding it and do-[n't] and what- tell me what color the strip is next to it.
M: Okay
Red. B: release the button when the timer has a one in any of the positions. M: Okay. It's gonna be a spell
M: Green good, we did it. Yaayy!!
B: Yeah, that's it right? M: y-yeaheheh.... That's fun!
For the record I've seen other people play this so that's why I have a general indication of what to say about things
But that's my first bomb, I did it!
B: You did it bud
M: I did it. Do you want to switch off every bomb or every few bombs?
B: uh, you could do a couple because I'm gonna start, not in the beginning.
So we're gonna have a little bit more complicated stuff when I'm- when I'm defusing. M: okay,
*giggling* Oh, that's not a good-. B: Actually I don't know if that's smart or not. Yeah, maybe I'll start, maybe i'll ease into it.
M: Alright, do I keep with the same bombs or do I go free play?
Oh god. B: Just keep like doing the progression of bombs because it sort of adds
Concepts and it sort of teaches you the game. M: Alright, *reading* something old something new. That's the next one
Alright, let's go. We've got a bomb... with... B: yep.
Do you want to know the...? Is it better to me to tell you what modules are on here?
B: Just pick a module. Then we could start there. It doesn't really matter. M: All right, we got funky symbols again
B: uh Just tell me what four symbols you have. M: Alright, we've got that backwards paragraph symbol the backwards P. We've got an upside-down exclamation
mark, we've got a six that got sqoOoshed on the top of it, and then we've got like there's a triangle headed squid with a
T coming out the side- left side of it and it's squid with that sideways T coming out the left side. B: okay
Yeah, yeah. Okay. So you're gonna press them in this order
Squishy six. M: squishy six. B: paragraph. M: Paragraph. B: Squid boy. M: Squiddy boy. B: Question mark. M: Bingo, we got it
okay, we've got
There's there's two green circles in it. There's a grid of like 6x6 and a red triangle. B: Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah
What is that one called? It's like the maze one. Here we go
okay, it's
Subject of the maze just find the maze with the matching circular markings. Okay. So the top leftmost circle you have two circles, right?
M: Yeah. B: Would- tell me where your top leftmost circle or leftmost like in the left half
It may not be on the top. M: Second column fourth row
B: Second column...
Fourth row, okay, so that means that you have another
Another circle that's four spaces to the right and two spaces up from that spot. M: Yes fifth column second row. Yes
B: Okay, cool. Cool. So
Which one is the white light in?
M: Third column first row. B: So now you're just gonna navigate the white light. Where do I have to get it to the red triangle?
Where's the red triangle? M: It is third column fourth row. B: Oh, that's a long one. Okay ready? M: Yup
B: We're gonna go left M: left
B: Down. M: Down. B: Left. M: Left. B: Down two. M: Down two. B: To the right. Now you should be in the circle
M: Yes. B: And then up one. M: Up. B: Right M: Right. B: Up
M: Up. B: Right
M: Right
B: We're like halfway there. Up.
M: Oh. Oh God
B: Right. M: Right. B: Down into the other circle. M: Down. B: Right. M: Right
B: Down. M: Down. B: Left two. M: Left two. B: Down one. M: Down one. B: And left one and that should be it right? M: Yep. That's it.
Bingo Bongo. All right, we got wires. B: Wires. There we go. How many? M: Six wires?
B: Six wires, are there any yellow wires? M: No yellow
B: What is the last digit of the serial number?
M: Urm, serial number...
B: It'll be on the side. It's a little tag. M: It's a two. B: No yellow wires
No, but if are there any red wires? M: One red fifth position?
B: Okay, cut the fourth wire, again. M: Gotcha. All right!
This is stressful! (I am also saying this while writing the subtitles :,-D)
B: Is that the hole bomb? M: Yeah, that was it yeah. B: Oh, okay. I thought you were just like, "Man!
Ohh. I need a break!"
M: No, no, that's it. Yeah we did great. That was great man. Thank You. B: How much time do we have?
Probably a couple minutes done. M: There was 132. Should I keep going with me. B: Yeah, let's do one more. M: Six modules.
Okay. B: We got this. M: All right, you know it baby. You know it
M: *exhale of air*
B: We haven't done anything yet!
M: Shut up! Shut up!
Alright. Alright. (Subtitle author is not ready for this)
We got wires. B: How many? M: Four. B: How many red wires are there? M: One red first position
B: Is there one blue wire? M: Yes. B: exactly one blue wire. Cut the first wire. M: Okay Green. We're good
All right. We got symbols. B: Tell me what you got. M: We got funky H backwards C with butthole
We've got a Z that's turned and curly on the ends or an N
That's curly on the ends a backwards n that's curly on the ends
I dunno. B: I gotcha
A big a T in it... *realisation* a with a penis. B: Ugh, a with dick. M: Mm-hmm. B: squiggle n. M: Squiggle n...
B: Squiggly h and backwards c. M: Got it. All right, we've got more symbols. B: Alright, what you got. M: We've got a
Railroad track or like a cross with another cross like if you put two crosses
*slapping noises*
You bring them together at the bottom of it two plus signs! B: Two plus signs. Got you. Got you. Got you
M: We got a e like in encyclopedia
B: Yep. Yep. M: We've got
candelabra, a u with an i. We've got Omega. B: All right, you're gonna push them in this order railroad tracks. M: Mm-hmm
B: a-e. M: Mm-hmm. B: u with an i in it, candelabra and then Omega. M: Okay. We're good green on that one. All right
B: Yes M: six more three more to go. We got a button white says hold
B: Is there a label anywhere on the bomb with the C-A-R on it?
Mark: uhhhhh, no. It says N-S-A Bob: Is-So there's no label next to a little it a light that says F-R-K either? Mark: N-No F-R-K, just N-S-A
B: What color was the button? Mark: The button's white. Bob: Uh-Press and hold the button, tell me what color the-the light is.
Mark: It's blue. Bob: Release the button when there's a four in any position on the timer Mark: Roger
Mark(cont.): Yay. Alright. Bob: Aw, yeah. Mark: We got we got wires-5 of them. Bob: 5 wires...Is the last wire black?
Mark: It's white. Bob: How many red wires are there? Mark: Zero. Bob: Are there any black wires at all? Mark: One. Third position. Bob: Cut the first wire.
Mark: Okay, we're good, one more button. Bob: *exhale* One more button. Alright, what's the color? Mark: *interrupting* Alright, it's yellow. Bob: What's it say?
Mark: Yellow-Says "abort".
Bob: uhhhh, press and hold it, and tell me the color. Mark: we got blue. Bob: So
Release when there's a four in any position on the timer. Mark: Okay.
Mark: We're done. *Throws hands in the air ans smiles like a happy little bean* Yayyyy! Bob: Ooooh!
Bob: *In a voice I can't describe* Yeaaaah! Mark: This is easy! Bob: Bro! Mark: Du-hu-hude!
Bob: It's so easy! Mark: I'm so good at this! Bob: Oh yeah!
Mark: *Is a genuinely happy bean* I'm the best! *Bob laughs in background* So good!
Bob: Why do you sound so sad and/or uncertain about that statement? *Mark starts laughing*
Mark: *Continues laughing* I'm just- Bob: *interrupting* I'm best! Mark: (cont.) I'm just really
proud of who I am as a person :)
Okay, I want a hard one! (I pray for thee, child)
Mark: Just-Ah,-oooh-Wait, okay. I can already go to Section three. Ooooh
Bob: Oh God. Mark: *Voice deepens for some reason* (I ain't complainin') Ahhhh
Okay, how about just this one this is one giant leap. Bob: Alright, hang on, I-I pulled the game up
So I got a uh- Mark: Oh! Do you want to switch out? We can switch out we go three and three- Bob: Uh- Mark: like every three.
Yeah, we could do that. Bob: Yeah, okay. Yeah. We'll switch out, we'll jump up to the hard ones for you next time
Mark: Alright, cool. So I'm just gonna keep, uh, actually I'm gonna switch to
The manual -boom-. Okay, got it. I'm ready
Bob: Ooh. Mark: I'm not gonna let you down. Bob: I-I believe. Mark: I don't even know where things are, so just you're gonna have to bear with me on
finding things. Bob: It's fine. We'll-We'll start
A little easy, and we'll give you a chance to learn how the thing works.*Mark giggles*  Oh! I don't have my saved game on this actually
So we have to do
Well, I have to do the easy ones, apparently, it's okay. It's okay. You can learn. Mark: Alright, I'm ready
I have got your back. Bob: Alright, we've got wires. Mark: *startled* You are-oh! we're starting now?! Oh, sh*t! Bob: we're in. We're all the way in. Mark: Okay, wires. Bob: It's happening. Mark: All right, how many wires?
Bob: Six. Mark: Alright. Um, are there any yellow wires? Bob: No. Mark: What's the last digit of the serial number? Bob: Uhhh
Serial number ends with a nine. Mark: *starts giggling at self* is nine odd or even
Bob: Nine is odd! *chuckles* Mark: Okay cut the third wire! Bob: Green. Alright, we've got a button. Mark: Okay
Button, yes. Bob: It is a blue button that says hold.
Mark: Blue-Uhhhh... Whaaaaa... *starts to panic* UUHH-HA-UHHH
Bob: You got it bud! Mark: UHHHH Bob: Read carefully
Mark: UUUHH- Oh! Uh,
Okay, umm-
Hold it-what color? Bob: red strip. Mark: Hit release when there's a one in any position
Bob: Green. Next one we got is symbols. Mark: Okay, this is perfect. It just goes one after another. Alright. *Bob Chuckles* What do we got?
Bob: *EXTREME SARCASM* I Didn't do that on purpose at all! I have the Omega, I have the squished six,
I have the candelabra and I have the-the train tracks thingy
Mark: Okay. Bob: Two plus signs. Mark: Do six, train tracks,
candelabra, Omega. Bob: Allll
Done. Mark: Did we do it? Bob: Yeah bomb-bomb defused! Mark: Ha ha! Yeah!
Bob: Civilians saved, I didn't die either!
Mark: That's awesome! Bob: It's a good day!
Mark: That's pretty good, right? Bob: *Laughs* That does-that did actually improve my personal best time by like 20 seconds *Mark starts laughing*
Mark: *still laughing* Yeah-ha-ah! This is-This is a fun game! *Bob starts laughing*
Bob: You sound-You sound surprised. Mark: It's fun! *starts laughing again*
It's fun!
My chat is saying you totally set that up for me, but *wheeze*
Bob: I may have accessed the modules in the order they appear and may known the answer to
Two of them before you said anything but it's fine. *More Markimoo laughter* It's fine. It's fine. Mark: You-You memorized the manual? Wow.
Bob: The wires-the wires and that-and the uh,
Symbols you do so much, that it's kind of easy to remember what shortcuts you have in the instructions Mark: Uh huh
gotcha. Bob: We're gonna do "Double Your Money". I'm in the top
17% in the world on "Double Your Money" already. Mark: Wooow. So I am so ready. Bob: I'm making Mark learn, chat!
Mark: I'm learning! I'm really learning!
Bob: Wires first. Mark: How many?
Bob: Six, sir. Mark: Alright, a yellow? Bob: No yellows. Mark: No yellows. Uh, what's the last of the serial number? Bob: Uh
It ends in a five.
Mark: Ok, that's odd. Definitely odd. Cut the third wire. Bob: Green on that one. Mark: Alright, alright. Bob: We have a-
Symbols. Mark: Okay, lay it on me. Bob: I could've done the next wires, but I did it wrong. *Mark chuckles*
Uh, uh, Backwards "N" with the squiggly ends
Mark: Alright. Got it.
Bob: A backwards "C" with the butthole. Mark: Uh-huh. Bob: "O" with a dick
Mark: "O" with a dick. Bob: And the lambda with the-with the little cross on the top part. Mark: Ok. Go "O"-dick, lambda, "N"
Squiggles, "C" butthole. Bob: Alright, we got another
Symbols one. Mark: I'm so ready. Bob: I've got a candelabra. Mark: Yep Bob: Backwards paragraph
Forward-facing "C" with the butthole. Mark: Uuuuh
Bob: And a black star. Mark: Okay. Go candelabra, "C" butthole, paragraph, star. Bob: Alright, back to wires.
We got another wires-six wires. Mark: Ok, six wires.
yellows two yellows two
Are there
Are there red wires?
No, red wires cut the last wire we're green on that one
Last thing we have is two buttons two buttons are I'm ready. The first one is a white button that says upward
Okay, is there a label that says car?
No
Okay
Preston see what color it is red, okay
Would look for a one position. Shut up music I have to wait
It's not fair for you to be all traumatic when I have to wait. Okay, next button. Alright
It's red and it says detonate that's not a good button
Okay, is there more than one battery on the bomb there are two batteries on the bomb, okay, press and immediately release
It's a trick it's all a trick it's fine. All right, cool. Oh great
There's there's a lot more modules in this man
Yet. Do you want to see some terrified bullshit scroll down to like Morse code?
Yeah, that's that's the correct response
Give me a hard one. Give you a hard one. All right?
Let's do pick up the pace. Shall we I like it. I'm only in the top
97% on this one. Oh, I solved this one with 2.9 seconds on the clock. I
Think it's gonna be fine. I think it's gonna be fine. Also also fine
Definitely all we got three minutes on the timer we started what's going it's going cymbals. Oh fuck. All right. What do we got? Okay
Omega
with six
Candelabra and a and with like a hat and a thing on it's right foot got it go six six
candelabra and
Omega done. All right the next two we haven't done yet
I have one that's got six buttons and at the top there's a word and each button has a word on it
I don't even know what this one's called. Okay, I think I know what you're talking about
It's like a black display and then six buttons with like rectangles beneath it ready
The display says red red got it. Okay
push the the
Second column middle. Alright one green light the display now says first on it, okay
Why isn't this in alphabetical order? Alright, first top right? All right
Checkmark, the display now says blank on it. Okay
second column middle done
Alright, the next one is a another display with a number in it
And then beneath it is four buttons that are like vertical rectangles. Oh
Okay, is the black button bigger and their numbers, right, yeah, they're numbers
The display is bigger and then the numbers there's four guns by side together. There's a correct button
What does the number in the big say it's a one okay, press the button in the second position
now it is a
2 press the button in the same position as before
so second position now, it is a a four press the button labeled four and now it is a
four
press the button in the
Second no
Wait, what what what position did we press the first time a second position? Okay second position. Yeah check mark
All right, the last this last one it says 1 ok, press 2nd position again done
Ok, twenty-six point three seconds left on the timer. I actually read that wrong, but I think it's ok
We just lucked out.
My camera died, no the camera. Alright, we gotta do this completely no camera.
Hang on, alright. Whats the last one?
It's all done.
Alright
26 seconds left
We did the second good thing totally wrong. I just got lucky on every answer. I think so. Yeah
My chat says, I'm the funniest one don't tell marker. Whoops
What?
No, I mean nothing. It's fine. I think I heard something about that. I could do this one called no room for error
That sounds like something we'd be good at
Yeah, one mistake and it's all over wipe the sweat off your palms and try not to let it get to you
Oh, so we only get one one goof. Well, we haven't goofy so far usually three goofs
Well, I trust you was gonna be great do it. I know we can do it
I don't like to see you thinking that I can do it. I'd like you to know
I know you can do it. I think you can do it because I know you can do it. All right
Okay, so from my lessons, I learned we're gonna go with wires first. Okay. We got six wires
Are there any yellows know yellows? What is the last digit of the serial number?
Zero are there any red wires two red wires? Okay, cut the fourth wire fourth wire green. We're good. Okay. There's one more wire
Uh-oh, if I could turn around. There we go. It is three wires three wires. Are there any red wires one red
Is the last wire white? No, it's blue how many blue wires are there one? All right cut the last wire
Okay, we're good. We got button. What do what do you got yellow or
white withold
Is there a little light next to a label that's as ciear on it
Yes, press and hold and tell me the color
It is white or at least when there's a one in any position you got it
Confirmed we're good go. Yeah. All right
We've got the the the words with the six word buttons. Got you. What's it say?
Yes, left column middle button, okay
kaboom
Didn't do it, right
Is that the one that we did wrong last I think it was you didn't do the second step last time
The instructions say look at the label of the button that's marked in step one
Yeah, and they use that a go to step two and push the first button that appears in the corresponding list. So we're just really
Close well, just randomly kick clicked and got three of them correct in a row
Alright man, it's ridiculous Assam is like simpler than that we cheated death
Alright, let's do it again. I understand and I will read the directions more closely this time so ready
It's good. We're good. We've got wires again. I think there's six of them
Are there any yellow wires one? Yellow how many white wires? Are there one are there any red wires one red cut the fourth wire?
Confirmed. All right, we've got symbols
Hell, yeah
Tell me tell me tell me got paragraph upside down question mark we've got a smiley face with its tongue sticking out
We've got a a B with it
T
You're gonna go paragraph is EB
Question mark smiley face got it confirmed kill confirmed
We've got wires again. How many four how many red wires are there zero?
Is the last wire yellow know is how many blue wires are there zero?
How many yellow wires are there to cut the last wire?
Okay confirmed. All right. All right. We got the wordy thing again. No Jam that trial fuck this one up real bad big
What is it says you are you are the letters or the words the words you why you Airy?
What does the rot what is the button right button say on it bottom right says you're with no apostrophe you're with no apostrophe
I'm gonna read words when I read one that you see click it. Okay. The first one is uh-huh
Next one is you space are?
The power went out. That's the power went out
Uh-huh
There is an aha
God we're good. Okay, we got that
Okay, it's dark that it says yes. Now, what is the middle left button? Say no
No, you have to tell me
Click the first one you see blank. Nope, ah with three H's. Nope. Wait. Yes
Okay, the next word is they're spelled th e, ir
It's the middle right button say middle, right? Aha
Uh-huh
Uh-huh, uh-huh
All right. Click what you see
Uh-huh, HOH. Okay, that's it. So, okay. We're good. We're clear. Okay
We've got big number for small number. Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha
What does the display say one?
Press the button in the second position, okay?
Gonna tell me the display I hit the snooze
Okay, it's oh, yeah. Sorry. It's a to press the button in the second position. Okay
The new number is a three press the button in the third position
Okay, new number is a one trust the button in the second position
Okay, new number is a three
What number did you press in the last stage in the last one? Yeah, what number not what position what number was on the button?
That's a great question. I think it was a four
I think you should click before then
I don't need to write this shit down. I can remember things. Okay, I forgot to ask. What number?
You're supposed to write things down should I get a notepad?
Right that that was not luck I
Remembered what it was?
My memory isn't that bad. I remember all my regrets
Yeah, he thought it was a four and it was so he thought correct. He doesn't say I don't know for maybe
Four terribly
Thanks, man, thanks for getting my back I really appreciate that thank you for the one who's gonna explode
Anyway, I'm not that worried about this. All right. This one's called fair game. No more hand-holding
Remember everything you've learned because anything can appear on this bomb. All right, let's do this. We've got oh my god. What is that?
There's no wires
There's no waters. Okay. What do you wanna do first I'd pick
Okay
there are there's something that looks like wires, but it's
Three and there's numbers on the left side and letters on the right side. It looks like a shoe lace there. Yeah
Sequences wire sequences, okay
There are several panels with wires on them
but only the one panel is visible at a time switch to the next panel by using the Deaf button and the previous panel by
using the up button do not switch to the next panel and
It was the right answer, oh did it checkmark? Yeah. Oh god, okay. Oh
Wait, but we need to know which oh shit. Do you remember what color wires there were red. Yeah, they're red
They were already. They're all red. Okay. What color worse do you have right now?
Is blue connected to B
Yeah, cut the blue wire that's connected to B to or connected to be
Cut both of them. No way when we cut one cup one cup one cut one. Sorry
Sorry one just one doesn't matter. Just one. You got it. And then
Is there a wire connected to a or C?
Not a SC cut the one connected to C. Got it. And I think we can go to the next panel go down
Whatever direction you went last time
It says wrong. No
Did it go back to like the top no it just stayed here
Shit, maybe cut the other one connected to B. I guess you got it it love that it really like that
Okay, we're looking at a blue and a black. Okay is the blue connected to beat no? Okay cut the black
Got it enough for the only two wires. Yes
Okay, next panel. We're good
Okay
We got a black and a red is the black connected to a or C a cut that one
Got it. And is the red connected to a or C a cut that one? Okay, and we're done with that pan
Okay, we're good. Okay. Yay, we we've got much time. We've got a two minute Oh
Oh, it amazed amazed amazed amazed
bobaloo tada
You're fine. You're fine
All right, where are the circles? Where's your furthest left circle fourth columns?
Sixth row fourth column sixth row is your furthest left. Yes. So your next one is fifth column third row. Yes
Okay. So where is your white dot fourth column fifth row? And where is your
red
Concentrate chart row. Okay, so we're gonna go up
up left 2 left 2
Up 1 ok. We're there. We're good. All right. Ok, ok. We've got Simon Says. Oh
yeah, I
Suck at this one yellow. Oh god. Everything went red. Don't don't push me
Think don't push me think no. I mean everything in the room is red. Okay
No strikes right foot push push green dream. I mean the yellow ones lighting up. Did I say that? Yeah, yellow flash
Yep. No, it didn't like green. It didn't like it didn't like green. It did not like green Bob. I'm gonna die
I think you might die. Oh
Wait, I'm sorry. We must be on the wrong one. Okay, we have one strike Gil fashion. It still says green know what?
You did
Talk to do from the grave now. Oh
We already had strikes oh shit that was overall strikes not strikes of the game damn it. I forgot how that role worked
Still still think this game is awesome. Yeah, it's awesome. Yeah, okay
All right, well your turn I guess I
Tried three times
That's fair fair's fair fair is fair
I'm gonna guide you to victory and I'm definitely not going to try to get you killed because you obviously
Sabotage me. All right. Well since fair's fair, we're gonna do fair game. All right the same one, right?
Oh, wait, that's where we did that already hang out. No, we'll do a different
Well, that was good because it was just a whole bunch of shit. I didn't know
All right, let's do it
Okay here you ready
I'm this is gonna it's fun. It's good. I have wires but they have stars on them
They're they're complicated wires. Well stars the bottom row has boxes and some of them have stars. They're not regular wires
They're complex wires. All right. Well, that's not on my that's all I found it. Okay
All right for each wire use the Venn diagram below to decide whether or not to get the fire at what
The first one is white with no star, okay
White you said, correct? Yeah, why?
Yeah, no star
Yeah is the led on?
No cut it
Okay, we're fine next one is no LED blue no star. Okay blue no star
What's the last digit of the serial number nine?
Don't cut it. Okay. The next one is blue and white with an LED, but no star
Okay, blue and white LED
Blue and white LED no star wait. Oh, I may have done something wrong
Have a parallel port does the Bob have oh
jeez
it has to to was a parallel port like a
DVI port no a parallel port let me look at the thing a parallel port is it it's like a DVI
But it has two rows
Long very low ports, no parallel. Okay, don't cut it
Okay. The next one is white with no LED and no star, but could no LED
No stars are the same as the first white one
Go ahead and cut that one. Okay, we're done
We have a button we can do buttons
All right, what's it say, it's white it says press
are there any
Batteries new batteries. Okay two batteries, okay
Press and tell me what color yellow? All right, look for a five crap. It has to go all the way around now
Okay, I don't want to stress you out. But we have a minute and 36 seconds left plenty of time
We have simon says we could probably do this
Alright, what's the colour? It's flashing?
blue
Flashing blue serial number ends in a nine and we have no strikes
Okay, go yellow wrong. Now. We have one strike. What is that? But it said Oh, does it contain a vowel? Oh, uh
Yes. Okay, go green
Got it. Now. It's giving me two blues screaming green green. Yeah, it gave me three blues. So green green green green time
Okay. Now we have to do Morse code in 30 seconds. Oh
Hi, the Morse code one. I've got I got it. I got it. Okay
short long short short short
Long short short short long short short that's about what to repeated letters
It's I mean, there's L. I mean, it's either
Three seconds per game they just throw these modules you've never seen before
Got you gotta be smarter than the PDF. I'm not
I'm not smarter, man. All right, we got this one. We got this one. Okay. Oh, yeah
All right
Now that I'm learned about the ones that we didn't get will be so fast watch this is gonna be so fast
All right. All right. We got a regular wires
Regular love it. Love it. I
Don't know
104 wires
All right. Is there a red wire to Red's? Okay, what's the last digit of the serial number?
It is a zero, okay
Are there any yellow wires? Oh wait. No one silo. Are there any blue wires? No blues. There was one yellow. Yes
Okay, cut the second wire. We're good. All right. Now we have complicated wires. All right, I'm ready. I did this one. We're good
Okay, what's the first one red and white with no LED and a star? What does it have a parallel port?
That's the two long one. Yes, it does
Cut it good. All right, what's next one is blue and white with an LED and a star blue
LED blue LED and white blue and white
Okay, blue white LED and a star is there there is a parallel port cut it okay
All right. The next one is red with no LED and a star right? That's loud. No LED and a star
Yeah, cut it the next one is blue and white with no LED and a star
Don't cut
Okay, the next one is blue and red
No LED, and no star blue and red
Yeah, no LED and a star-cut it and the last one I have to cut because it's not done. Okay, we're done
Next I have number-big number display with four buttons. Okay, big number four buttons. What is it? One.
Okay, press the second position. I'm gonna- I'm busting out notepad for this because- okay-
I want to make sure you don't die. Now I have a four. So one-a four- Same position, which was second position. Yep.
I pressed a three that round, -okay- and now it says a four
okay, press the button labeled four. That's in the first position, -Mhm- and
Now I have a two. Okay, press the same-The button in the first position
Alright, that's a two in the first position and now it says three
okay, press the button with the same label you press in stage four, which was a -
Yep, done. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah now we have Simon Says. Alright
Was the flashing. Oh, wait is does the serial number, lol?
No vowels no strikes and it's flashing green. All right hit green. Yep that gave me
Green red green red green blue. Yep, and now it gave me green red blue green
Blue yellow and now it gave me green red blue red
Green blue yellow blue done. Alright
The last one is a display with five letters showing on it and it has an arrow above and below each letter to cycle it
So we can we have to like spell a five letter word. Got it
Okay
The buttons above and below each letter will cycle through the possibilities only one combination of letters available will match the password below
Press the submit button when the correct one has been
okay, so the options for the first letter r
U u y y z s
D and M
Okay, it's s okay
What what are my options for s?
Just small sound spell still study small sound spell still study. Yeah, you're looking for M
Opt and M opt. I have a P. I'm gonna go for spill. Yeah. It's
Better spell spell yeah
Oh
21 seconds left. Oh my god
Hey
No prob
Holy shit
Totally killed it
Two percent, that's not for good
And to win has finished this with a minute and 11 seconds left on the flow shit
Okay
We're gonna do we're gonna do eight minutes
That's a lot of minutes eight minutes. Oh eight modules. Oh god, that's good, though, because take your time relax
It says okay fine. Thanks game
Thanks, Vinnie video game for your encouragement. Oh my god. Fuck have you started pay?
We have a button. Let's do the button that's relaxing
Alright, but it's red and it says hold okay, if it's red
It says hold press and release ha ha, all right, let's do there's one that's got three wires and on the left
It says one two three and on the high that says ABC shoelace
Okay. All right
Okay
What do you see a by a one black and two blues
Okay is the red connected to see?
Black and to
Just go ahead and cut that black one. I don't even care what it's do then there's the first blue is connected to a
Huh?
The second blue is connected to C
All right, what does it mean by occurrence
So the from the top down there one two, and three so the first blue is the highest blue I have on here
Ah, just you have to keep track of how many we've seen as we go through the panels
You said the second one was connected to what C cut the second one and we're done
Yeah, okay, that's good. I have another another blue
That's our third blue, which is connected to a don't cut shred is connected to B
Okay, don't cut that either. All right now, all right
The second red is connected to a don't cut it third red is connected to C
Don't cut it. The fourth blue is connected to a
Cut it. Dunzo. All right, the
Fourth some of the red the next thread is C the third or fourth. It's the four
It's connected to a four thread connected to a got it fifth red connected to be cut it done
That's easier when you when you say it like that. It's super easy. Yeah, we got to do the
Words display with six words under it one. All right, I'm ready
It says you are you space. Are you space are?
Okay, what does it say in the bottom, right?
Aha with the h-huh. Okay. I'm gonna read you words. Oh, yeah, huh son Oh, okay
All right, this display says the letters you are right next to each other you are top left
No. All right. Here we go
blank
Done, okay
It says they are
they are two separate words today space our middle left o
With three H's. Okay ready?
nothing
left
Undone done done it he done done now. We got a regular wires six wires six wires
All right. Any yellows one? Yellow any White's one white are there any Reds?
No Reds
Cut the last wire tons. Oh, we got symbols. We know symbols. We can be similar. No symbols. I like symbols
I've got a candelabra. Yep and Omega. Yep the backwards e with eyeballs on top
Oh, yeah, and a backwards H. No an end thing with big with a hat and a foot
Okay, do that II think yeah candelabra
Yep, the N and the Omega Danzo. We got numbers big number with four numbers under it. All right, I'm ready
I'ma write down two okay to press the second position
Which is a number three, okay, it says
1 press the button labeled four that's in the third position. Ok, it says
Press the button in the third position
That's a number one. Mm-hmm. It's
is for
Press but in the same position the same position you pressed as in stage two
Which was I believe this aim?
No, it was the one labeled four which was you said it was in the third position. Yep, okay
That was a number one. I just pushed and the screen says one, okay
Same label you pressed in stage one, which was a three done. All right, we have another
Wires three wires a B and C thing situation one. Okay. All right. Yeah, I'm ready
The first black wires going in to be cut second black wires going into a cut
Alright next panel third black wires going into C. Don't cut first red wires going into C cut
Okay, the second red wires going into B cut the first blue wires going into a don't cut
The second blue wires going into B. Do not cut all
right
the black wire whatever number it is is going into C third fourth cut and then the red wire going into a
Cut and then a black wire going in to be cut dunzo. Alright save the best for last, it's Morse code time
Okay, how much time we get?
two minutes
Okay, I got long short short short long
short short short, that's B short long
Short short short long short short short short short
Long, oh, I I get what you're long
Short short short
Okay, long short short short short
short
Long, it's beets. It's 3.6
3.6 even 3.6 even done
We did the whole thing